i got a surprise for you oh that's
surprising
i want to show you something oh and show
me come here yes
it's a beer and a little bear yeah
welcome to manhattan baby so beautiful
everything i know from new york just for
movies do you feel the energy in the
city
i feel with you i you you give me energy
notes
oh you give me energy too
i can't believe we're really here
together babe
yeah let's go inside oh although
he doesn't really speak a lot of english
like our sexual chemistry
it's like an unspoken language we have a
deep connection
that him and i will only know
i'm glad you're here oh
babe come on i got us this nice hotel
there's nice place
and we're in new york city together god
he's like falling asleep on me right now
so i feel a little underappreciated i
did all this
expecting him to be more excited to see
me and
you know love on me and i just
envisioned
our first night together in america to
be like a fairy tale
[Music]
i've been waiting five long years for
this and he better not disappoint